okay we saw there were situations where
soft margin wasn't going to help us and
so we're going to find ways of of
overcoming this problem and a natural
way to do that
is using feature expansion so what we
can do one simple way is a standard
trick is in larger features by including
transformation
transformations such as polynomials
right so we started off with just in
this example just x1 and x2 we can add
in x1 squared
x2 squared x1 cubed
x1 x2 and so on right polynomial
expansions so you can go from a
p-dimensional space in this case 2 to a
higher dimensional space and the more
transformed variables you add
um the more likely you are to be
able to get separation in this higher
dimensional space i just know something
the m there of course is not the same m
as we used for margin oh so that's a
good point maybe we should use different
letters yeah okay
thank you
that was a
bad choice of uh
of letter that's usually the kind of
mistake i make
i'm glad i caught you on one final it's
the kind of mistake i hate making
so
in larger feature space and then fit a
linear support vector machine in the
enlarged space
and then when you
project it down to the original space
that results in a it results in a
non-linear decision boundary in the
original space
so for example
suppose we we use
degree two polynomials so we'll use x
one x two x one squared x two squared
and x one times x two
so that's a basis for fitting a general
polynomial in two variables of degree
two
well in the enlarged space the decision
boundary would take this form it's it's
it's linear in the new variables
right
so there's a coefficient for each of
them so that was the form of our
separate of a hyperplane
but of course in the original variables
it's non-linear because we've got
squares and and cross products okay
and
this is what it results in in for the
same example that we saw
the decision boundary you can see it's
kind of split into now so remember how
do we get these these decision
boundaries in the in the
five-dimensional space there's a single
linear decision boundary okay and we can
color all the points on one side blue
and on the other side move
well if you project it down into this
two-dimensional picture of the original
variables this is what it looks like
so these are conic sections of a
quadratic
polynomial
and and this is what they look like
and it's curious because in the
five-dimensional space there's a margin
on either side of the linear boundary
which are the dotted lines well they
also project down and so there's a pair
of margins for this piece of the the
curve and one for this you'll notice
these are non-linear and they even ends
up in two pieces here
and
importantly in this case this does a
really good job in separating the two
classes
okay
here's the equation
in in this case it's it's a cubic we
used a cubic polynomial in this case
so
there's nine
transform variables all together
and so it starts getting a little
unwieldy the dimension of the space is
getting a little bigger but it does it
solves the problem
okay well
so we seem to have a way of getting
around these situations where we can't
uh separate the data
now polynomials aren't the greatest
choice because especially in high
dimensions they get wild rather fast we
know even in regression we don't like
doing polynomial regression with degree
bigger than three
and and if you've got a large p to start
with and if you have a full
even cubic polynomial space it's quite a
large space
so it turns out there's a more elegant
and controlled way to introduce
non-linearities in support vector
classifiers and this is through the use
of what's known as kernels
but before we get into these we need to
understand the role
of inner products in support vector
classifiers
okay so in the products we um
if you've got a
set of vectors so we've got x i and x i
prime now remember x i is a p vector
it's a set of variables for observation
i
and x i prime is another p vector
and this angle notation here means inner
product between these two vectors and
it's just the sum of cross products of
each of the individual components of the
vector so that's called the inner
product between two vectors and we write
it in this in this in this compact way
over here
so using that notation we can write a
linear support vector classify can you
can write it in this form over here
and
and so here we have an inner product
between
each of
the xi's in the data
and the target point so we're thinking
about this is a function of a new point
x
and it turns out you can write the the
support vector machine
classifier solution in this form
now you're not going to be able to see
that just from looking at the formula
for the linear function this turns out
to be how it comes out in the solution
but it's going to be important
it also turns out to estimate the
parameters so now we've got n parameters
instead of the p
and n could be bigger than p to estimate
the parameters
and beta naught
all we need are all the pairwise inner
products between all the endpoints in
the data set
so there's going to be a n by n
in a product matrix and it turns out
that if we have that
and that's all we have
we can fit the support vector classifier
and represent it in this form and it's
going to give us the same solution as
what we had before
now when you do that
what happens is that many of the alphas
end up being zero right so here we put
hats on the alphas
and many of them are zero and so the
only ones we need to include here are
the ones that aren't zero and so we call
those a support set
or the support vectors
and so those
are the alphas that are not zero and
each alpha is tied to
one of the original points or vectors in
the original data set
so we'll go back to slide eight and see
which ones those are
so let's get back here to slide eight
here's slide eight
so which are the support vectors or the
points with non-zero
alphas
well in this left picture over here
there's the two circle points those are
support vectors and also any points on
the margin
so it looks like this one and this one
and
possibly this one
so in this case it'd be
five support vectors
so of all the points in the picture only
five of them would have non-zero alphas
and it sort of makes sense right
certainly the ones on the margin make
sense because they define in the
direction
but the ones inside are also going to
define the direction because remember
they have these little
epsilons tagged onto them
and so they're going to play some role
in the in the definition of the
direction
in this one over here
there's one two three four five six
seven
support points and just to add to that
right if a point's not a support point
it means it's on the right side of its
margin and if we if we moved it but we
kept it in the same area it's not going
to affect the solution so they're not
support points
and one more thing to add this is the
kind of sparsity but it's kind of a
funny sparsity right remember we talked
about the lasso
it produced a sparse solution in the
coefficients of the features this is a
kind of sparsity but it's different it's
actually in the in the data space right
because now we're assigning a weight to
each data point and some of these
weights are zero and the ones that are
nonzero are called the support points so
sparsity but in the in the data space
not the feature space
that's a good point robin you know and
when you think of it like that you say
suppose you had a thousand points and it
ends up that there's 10 support points
you think oh great you could have thrown
away the other 990 points
well not really because you had to have
them all there to decide which ones
would be the support points once you
found them you can throw them away but
it doesn't really help much in the in
the computations right
so it's a very interesting topic support
vector machines and it took us a while
to understand
the details
okay so that's in the products
now what about kernels
so
from the from what we saw previously if
we can compute the inner products
between all pairs of observations
and if we can also compute the inner
products between all the training
observations and a new test point
then we can both fit the support vector
machine and evaluate the function
okay
so this can be quite abstract
first of all an inner product is is like
a similarity and so if if you didn't
really have data and you just had
similarities pair wide pairs wise
similarities between observations in
principle you could come up with a
classifier and there have been some
interesting examples of that so it
allows us to be a bit more abstract
but
more importantly there's some special
kernel functions so these are a kernel
function is a function of two arguments
in this case two p vectors right
so it's called a bivariate function
and these
these kernels compute the inner products
for us
and you might not even know what the
feature space is in which they compute
in the inner product but they can be
thought of as doing that
but a concrete example is with
polynomials so here's a bivariate kernel
function look at it
this part here is just the inner product
between the original vectors
x i and x i prime
we add a 1 to it
and we raise it all to the power d
and it turns out that this kernel
computes the inner product in a feature
expansion space that we get by expanding
these vectors in these p components into
a basis for d dimensional polynomials
sorry d degree d polynomials
well that can be a huge space if p is
large and d is large
the number of basis function is actually
p plus d
choose d
which which grows
very fast as p and d grow fast so that's
a very big dimensional space potentially
but we don't need to actually visit that
space because this function will compute
those inner products
it's sort of like magic you've got a
kernel function that computes this inner
product in this in this very high
dimensional space
so
try a little
try a little example with with p is two
so like in our example we had two
components in x and d is two
and just expand this function and see
what you get and you'll see that indeed
it does just what i said
and having done that
we can therefore compute the n by n in a
product
matrix for all the the n observations by
evaluating this function at each pair
and then we get a solution
which is of this form because again k is
computing the inner product between the
target point x and and each of the x i's
in the sample and once again these alpha
eyes are going to be non-zero for only
those points in the support set
so that's where the kernel comes into
the to the support vector machine
one of the most popular kernels is
called the radial kernel
and it's defined like this
if you know what a multivariate gaussian
distribution looks like this is the
important part of that distribution
it's a sum of squares between the
components x i and x i prime each of the
elements
there's a gamma here so there's a tuning
parameter that's raised to the power e
and this is an inner product
in an abstract
infinite dimensional feature space
so this is a very high dimensional space
so high we could never visit it yet this
kernel computes the inner product for us
and we can therefore fit a support
vector machine
and in our example where we had the two
classes separate in the move class the
two blue classes this is the solution
that it gave
and again it seems to have done a really
good job
okay
so
something's got a little weird here how
can we fit models in an infinite
dimensional feature space and not be
over fit in the data
well it turns out that even though it's
an infinite dimensional feature space
many of the dimensions are squashed down
heavily
in fact almost squashed down to zero
so it's a very high dimensional feature
space but
most of the space is squashed down
and
the the dimensions that are squashed
down tend to be the more wiggly
dimensions the smoother ones are
squashed down less
you'll notice when you if you if you
went through this little example over
here you'll notice that
it was a it did give you the inner
product between a degree two polynomial
but there were coefficients in front of
these and those
are what give you the squashing factors
so trevor in that example in polynomial
kernels i could take d to be a million
right you're going to have a huge number
of polynomial functions
which if i did with the feature
expansion method i would things would
get out of control so so what happens
here you run into trouble raising power
right to a million yeah with a
polynomial kernel i can get away with
that you can get away with it yeah and
that's because of the squishies of all
the squishing down yeah
okay so
a radial kernel is very popular and it's
one of the most popular kernels it's
used
for non-linear
support vector machines
and
the other kernels but this is the one
people usually go to
and this gamma is a tuning parameter
and
if you make if you make
you can think of it like the standard
it's like one over the standard
deviation of the gaussian
so if gamma's really large it's like
having a small standard deviation
and and you get much more wiggly
decision boundaries
whereas if gamma's small the decision
get boundaries gets smoother
so
we're going to take this machinery and
then next segment and and look at
an example